[موسيقى]
انا اشتغل في في كتب المستعمله والقديمه
منذ سنوات ولدت من الاب ديالي رحمه الله
تعالى عليه وبركاته
وكذلك رئيس الجمعيه الجهويه للكتبيين
بمناسبه ديال شهر رمضان دابا حنا ان شاء
الله الرحمن الرحيم في 2023 يكون عندنا
الدوره 23 ديال المعرض ديال رمضان
بالضبط ان هذه مناسبه للاخوه اللي شغوفين
بهذا العديد المجمعين الكتب
مناسبه اننا تنخرجو كل ما عنا من الكتب
قديمه مستعمله في التراث بجميع الاصنافها
بجميع موادها بما فيها التاريخ
والتراث الاسلامي واللغات وجميع اللغات
بما فيهم العربيه الانجليزيه الاسبانيه
المانيه اللي ولا حتى كذلك واحنا هذا فرصه
باش يكون لقاء بيننا وبين المثقفين ديالنا
والرواد
كل شهر هذه ما هي على المكتبات
[موسيقى]
هنا دابا هاد الموسوعات نعطيكم مثال هذا
عنده واحد تقريبا واحد ستين ولا سبعين
ديال القرن التاسع العشرين وكتب التاريخ
هادو اللي كانوا الفرنسيين في المعاهد
الفرنسيه تتشتغل كاين على المغرب
كتب نادره بما فيهم الكتب المسفره بحال
هذا الشكل اللي تتكون قريره قليله هذا
نعطيكم غير امثله ديال واحد المجموعه
الكتب
نادره حنا تنحتفظ بها هنايا بالنسبه للناس
اللي
يبحثوا عليها ها هما وعندنا الناس اللي
تنوجدوهم لبعض الخزانات وهذه حنا دابا
الانف ديال واحد المجموعه ديال الطلبات
وكاينين شي كتب لي غير مثال الاستئناس
اللي كانت موجوده في السوق بحال ديوان عبد
الرحمن مجدوب بحال المتعه في شرح المقنع
كاين بحوت الكثيره هنايا ناخذ مثال بحال
دابا هذا الكتاب
تقريبا هذا
تاريخ ديالو تقريبا
حتى هو غادي يكون عندو واحد فوق 100 سنه
والزياده
كيف دايره يعني هاد الامورات هي اللي
تنشتغلو عليها حنا وما اكثرهم ها هما
وعندنا هنايا واحد الجناح
او مقص انا يعني مثال عاوتاني دعوه الحق
هذه اللي مجله مغربيه وما اكثر واحد العدد
كبير ديال المجلات البينه تاريخ المغرب
ملفات من تاريخ المغرب
الوثائق الوثائق الملكيه الاولى هادو مثال
غير دابا بالصدفه حنا قلينا هادو هادو هنا
هادو الاجانب اللي كانوا في المغرب تيجوا
كانوا تيقراو وكاتبين كتب على المغرب هذا
سميتو يلاه هذا دابا يتعلم اللغه العربيه
الدارجه ها هو كتاب فريد
ها هو ديال التعليم كيفاش كانوا الاجانب
تيقراو اللغه العربيه
وهما اللي طبعوه وكاين هذا
يعني التعليم اللغه العربيه الدارجه هذا
ديال يونس
واحد الفتره
الطريقه باش يتعلموا العربيه
هادو كلهم كانوا في المدارس
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات